morning Skelly how was your weekend fun
Kelly and I hit the park went for a long
walk fell asleep watching TV oh sounds
like a fun weekend with Kelly so Kelly
is that skul's wife or his
dog wait no one knows kl's wife's name I
think Kelly is his dog went for a long
walk that's what you do with a dog you
can go on a long walk with a person at
Sunset talking about nothing and
everything sounds awful hit the park
that's a dog my wife takes the B to the
park all the time all right we're doing
this let's play wife or dog hey so
Skully what do you do at the park with
Kelly oh we just walk around she gets
ansy if she doesn't get outside enough
and then it's just yap yap yap all day
long hey what's Kelly's favorite food
peanut butter she'll eat it right out of
the jar how old is Kelly again well
she's getting up there but she's pretty
Sprite for her age especially
considering she got hit by that car a
year ago oh that's so awful is she
chasing something into the street or n
just getting me the newspaper all right
this is useless Scully is Kelly your
wife or your dog how can you ask me
that I still don't know which it is it
could be either could not tell you yeah
it's full of treats it's got Meats
cheeses candies all the food groups the
cheese is amazing it melts in my mouth
and in my hands huh French chocolates
French cheeses tiny French pickles did
none of you detectives think this might
be a gift for captain from someone in
France like his husband po examp
what no way this is a nice present from
an unknown appreciative citizen that
wanted us to munch what's this then dear
Captain Raymond Hal thinking of you best
Dr Kevin Cosner PhD he even used their
pet names oh no I ate the chocolate
covered strawberry that's the most
intimate snack of them all H's going to
be back from his meeting in 30 minutes
what do we do e the not no no it's okay
we can fix
this check it out sir a lovely gift
basket that Kevin sent you all the way
from Paris Straight From
Paris
stapler
scissors rubber
bands that man really knows
me come here come here come come here
you got to see this I'm about to give
Captain Holt his gift oh did he lift his
no gift policy no he didn't but I
figured out a way to buy him something
and trick him into accepting it you are
bad I know right oh wait you're making
fun of me mhm well I don't care he would
never open a gift right but what if his
gift didn't look like a gift he would
open it exactly I left it in a cardboard
board box on his desk there's no card
just the words open now which I wrote
with my wrong hand so he wouldn't
recognize my
handwriting Captain Santiago Coro sir so
just to recap you left an unmarked
package on a police Captain's desk on a
random Monday with a suspicious message
written on it that looked like it was
scrolled by a crazy person mhm bomb
there's a bomb everyone out let's go
let's go this is not a drill let's
go great gift
babe okay hold
me nothing my mouth wa impressive are
you kid me that's a nothing Diaz has
been chucking de holes in on my
mouthpiece since we were back at the
Academy check this
[Music]
out I'm capabilities and
now don't agree with how I
do my
is
uhoh what
the it's finally happening CL gobble
gobble guess who just came from the
ps321 Thanksgiving Parade Charles you
actually Charles I'm Tommy gobler and
I'm stopped with Thanksgiving happiness
a gobble Goble seriously I warned you
I'm TI Tommy gobler you silly Pilgrim
okay Tommy gobler there you go these are
the
Davidsons they want to know what
happened to their missing
grandmother I have some deeply tragic
news for
you pigeon still here yeah no matter
what we do you just won't leave the
problem is you're thinking like
detectives no I'm definitely not when
you should be thinking like a
bird this is Operation Saving Private
pigeon on my Mark I will turn on this
fan gently startling our bird dup East
into the filebox canyon where he will
encounter Charles holding two pot lids
he'll bang them together forcing private
pigeon into the ceiling there and out of
the ceiling there where he will be
greeted by scary Rosa holding a scary
picture of an owl now he's playing our
game K left into an upside down garbage
can propped up by a hockey stick and
connected to a string that Gina is
holding she pulls it he's trapped and
Terry releases him outside Terry hates
Birds okay little friend let's get you
home to
Mama
oh God it flew right into the fan it's
everywhere there's pigeon everywhere
good morning everyone oh my goodness sge
what are the chances I say zero oh I
mean when Genevie got me these
suspenders I thought I'd lean into it
and go for the whole look but I didn't
want to step on your toes that being
said you know what this means don't do
this Charles oh it's already done gather
around y'all it's time to play who wore
best I'd really rather not because you
would chck chicken who wore it best who
wore it best who wore it best Terry what
come on you should change
Bo not here ant ant ant ant ant God
they're everywhere are we sure that
we've cleaned up all the food and
crumbs why is everyone looking at us
we're the ones who eat up all the crumbs
yeah we're the solution well there are
no ants on my desk because I sanitize it
daily what do you call that
those are door ants they're using a
monitor cable as a land
bridge now they're destroying our
technology this is an invasion they're
in my yogurt now it's personal all right
that's it we have got to fight back this
is our planet just use Bo's cologne it's
repulsive to everything not cool you're
going to Penn Station and buy me a new
one the ant infestation it's bad they
bite now sir I think they're just trying
to avoid the cold weather we should
freeze them
out
the plan is working Captain yes we won
oh my God they're in the coats they're
in our
coat 5 4 3 2 and step and step and knes
around the world great form Captain your
Cals are looking toy car what are you
doing at razmataz we needed to talk
somewhere outside the precinct Diaz you
were here too great yeah sir we've
discovered that Lieutenant Hawkins is
dirty her Squad isn't investigating the
gold gang bank robbers they are the
robbers knees up in the back sorry
Brenda if Hawkins is robbing banks why
she invite you onto a task force and
squat and hold and work those quads we
were working on a case that could have
exposed her this way she can keep tabs
on us turn it get down Cow why is this
so hard for me do I even have quads and
twirl normally I'd say we'd report this
to Internal Affairs and twirl back but
Hawkins is one of the most revered
detectives in the NYPD and hola hands if
you you going to go after her you better
have the proof to back it up well then I
guess that only leaves us one option and
now wag those Tails find out everything
we can about the squad and take her down
from the inside keep wagging back there
I am wagging Brenda ladies and gentlemen
we are gathered here today to answer an
age-old question right what's Amy's deal
is she single no we're dating come on
the question is who here does the best
impression of Captain Rayman Holt you
will be judged on voice body language
and overall lack of flare everyone will
perform the same scenario Captain halt
eating a marshmallow for the very first
time let the HT off begin what is this
glutenous monstrosity before me the
sugar in this is quite
sweet that's your halt impression I
could hear him doing that looks like a
sticky pillow I don't care for it
classical
music what's going on here what are you
doing Captain hey nothing just eating
some marshmallows care for one
marshmallow
I knew it listen up everyone we had a
murder this morning the Vic was found at
8:45 by a dog walker who led herself
into his apartment oh my God it's frania
this is the work of Johnny frania my
white whale he's finally resurfaced not
this again yes this again Johnny frania
has been on a murder spree for the past
10 years and every time he kills someone
he taunts me look there's a deck of
cards you say that whenever there's
cards at a crime scene you know how many
people people own cars Jake then explain
this Johnny Fran's catchphrase is deuces
are wild now look around the apartment
two chairs two paintings two pillows
they three lamps you think frania gives
a damn about lamps you sound so dumb
right now this is why you don't have an
arch nemesis Terry because you focus on
the wrong details maybe I don't have an
arch nemesis because I solve all my
crimes that's a pretty Fed Up thing to
say to me hey there Bo how's your your
weekend well actually I got a little
sick oh really I'm sorry to hear that
man yeah Bullets Over Broadway was on TV
and I came down with a big old Diane
whis
infection like
ye
that